rafael vous dites stop aux
manifestations jeudi nice non je dis ni
stock ni encore jeune je crois que le
truc est mort je le crois que c'est
d'ailleurs c'est assez bizarre
finkielkraut a tué nuit debout par sa
seule présence comme il a tué d'une
cette manière les gilet jaune en
révélant quelque chose qui n'aurait pas
dû être enfin comment dire et c'est sa
seule présence a provoqué quelque chose
de tellement explosif l'antisémitisme
j'entends jérôme rota gaz qui condamne
l'antisémitisme c'est très important de
le faire de le dire c'est que cette
histoire est aussi l'occasion pour tout
le monde
de rappeler à quel point on le condamne
mais l'antisémitisme c'est pas
simplement la haine des juifs c'est ça
que je veux dire l'antisémitisme c'est
un système d'explication du monde c'est
un système d' explication globale qui
repose sur le sentiment que les juifs
possèdent ou posséderait le pouvoir dont
les autres seraient dépourvus le fonds
de commerce de l'antisémitisme c'est le
sentiment que les juifs sont des nantis
des cancrelats sournois qui possède un
pouvoir dont les autres sont dépossédés
et cette façon de penser odieuse est
tout à fait compatible avec le discours
de beaucoup de gilet jaune et qu'il
s'agit pas de dire que les gilet jaune
sont antisémites
mais il s'agit de dire aussi qu'il y a
dans ce discours là dans le discours
dans le sentiment général qu'ont et
dépossédé de ce dont manque dans ce
sentiment là il y a quelque chose de
propice à l'antisémitisme
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut travailler
il suffit pas dire que les juifs sont
nos frères
ou que naturellement on déteste
l'antisémitisme il faut travailler le
fond du discours et le fond du discours
c'est de faire au monde leurs proches de
ce qui ne va pas chez soi et ça c'est un
problème qui à mon avis fait que
l'antisémitisme prospère dans ce
mouvement
maintenant juste un dernier mot la
raison pour laquelle à mon avis ce
mouvement ne pourra pas précipiter c'est
le sort d'ingrid le bafa levasseur c'est
un mouvement qui au départ et c'est sa
noblesse d'ailleurs refuse toute forme
de représentation et jacqueline et le
refus donc jacqueline mot refuse toute
forme de représentation de sorte qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya un représentant
quelqu'un qui qui qui il sort un peu du
du lot immédiatement il se fait abattre
par les autres ou rappelé à l'ordre le
résultat de ça c'est que ce mouvement
qui est très puissant dans le rejet est
très faible dans le projet on est
incapable et le gilet jaune les premiers
d'énumérer dans la même liste toutes
leurs revendications et c'est là qui à
mon avis une faiblesse qui fait que ça
peut se recommander indéfiniment tous
les samedis cette année une expérience
de fraternité c'est un moment de
solidarité c'est un moment important
pour des tas de gens on peut le
renouveler indéfiniment
mais ce qu'on veut nous
ran aura n'arrivera pas à précipiter en
projet politique et c'est ça mon regret
moi mon regret c'est que du coup ça ne
débouche pas sur des propositions une
force politique
une liste aux européennes bref quelque
chose de constructif
un projet plus qu'un rejet voilà choses
se construisent monsieur je l'espère
d'accord vous le savez mieux que moi
choses se construisent d'accord
maintenant on est des cons et qui nous
on est des plombiers pour ma part
d'autres femmes ouvriers notre son
commerçant et vous n'êtes pas loin de
chômage en suisse pour composer un
moment donné vous croyez quoi ça fait 40
ans que vous avez des gouvernants
quelques mois vous me dites un rejet par
rapport aux juifs parce qu'ils auraient
le pouvoir tout puissant et voit le seul
rejet de ges et nous gouvernons je ne
sais pas à qui il appartient à quoi ils
appartiennent ils ont rien fait pour
nous pendant 40 ans ils ont été
incapables de monter un projet pour que
les françaises vivent mieux et vous
allez demander à nous en trois mois
2 pour construire un projet béton on est
dessus monsieur est ce que j'en dis aux
loisirs avec fillon si on prend monsieur
macron qui a monté son parti en six mois
avec des compétences le pognon qui va
avec
vous voulez quoi de nous on est là vous
inquiétez pas j'ai dressé on va dire que
c'est une question une bonne question
[Applaudissements]
une question alors j'entends ce que vous
me dites il ya du boulot derrière je
vous jure qu'à dû à cuba mais j'en suis
sûr je voudrais comprendre une chose les
gilets jaunes ont obtenu beaucoup de
choses depuis l'avant et c'est bien 10
milliards non attend toujours les pots
de vie dont monsieur gilles et je ne
sais pas vous mais aussi les jeunes ont
obtenu beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
choses plus que tout mouvement syndical
au 20e siècle
si on liste les choses entre le smic les
indemnités kilométriques et le grillage
on n'est pas citée il y avait donc il ya
eu des choses me paquin a suspendu jeudi
des tracts ça joue sur les mots laissez
moi finir je reste mais c'est réciproque
si vous me laissez moi finir je vous ai
laissé finir les émois finir par leurs
dons tremblay gilet jaune ont obtenu
lundi toute chose ils ont obtenu
beaucoup de choses pas assez mais ils
ont obtenu beaucoup de choses ne
changent pas ce qui m'étonne mais je
voudrais finir mais les mots sont
importants mais je voudrais finir quand
même c'est important de rester c'est
réciproque
je voudrais finir vous avez obtenu
beaucoup de choses et ces choses là il
est heureux que vous les ayez obtenu
reste que moi je ne comprends pas c'est
comment se fait-il que chaque fois qu'il
ya une conquête chaque fois qu'on
obtient quelque chose la colère est
relancée alors que si si ce sont les
doléances qui justifie le mouvement
quand on obtient quelque chose la colère
doit baisser eh bien non quand on
obtient quelque chose on se dit qu'on va
pouvoir obtenir la vraie
mais la directivité nom tellement de
problèmes la tolère la revendique la
colère on laisse répondre colère la
dirige team et qu'il est celle de la
majorité des gilet jaune
d'accord c'est une colère qui est
maîtrisée de preuve en est ils sont
encore là malgré tout c'est des gens qui
sont en grande difficulté
et si le mouvement continue c'est qu'il
ya des gens qui sont dans le désespoir
et quand on est dedans désespoir on va
jusqu'au bout et jusqu'au bout et que la
dignité
après c'est malhonnête de la part de
certains médias et de certains
politiques de se focaliser sur des
individus extrêmement violent que tout
le monde condamne c'est comme pour les
matchs de foot c'est comme pour dans
d'autres sphères vous avez de la
violence non je focalise pas là dessus
un moment donné il faut passer outre
il faut aller sur le fond des problèmes
de fond du problème c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de français qui souffrent et
des français qui souffrent parce qu'ils
travaillent et vous avez également des
français qui sont travailleurs et qui
sont également dans la misère
à cela s'ajoutent aussi des migrants
vous trouvez dans nos rues du cap les
français qui sont dans nos rues tout ça
c'est le millefeuille france est donc un
moment donné il va falloir des caps est
valorisée 1 pour mieux repartir
est-ce qu'il faut pas partir maintenant
qu'il est un peu le terrain pour mieux
repartir je pense qu'il faut avoir un
discours apaisant humanité je pense
qu'il faut un discours apaisé contre
relève surtout